bonsoir très heureux d'être à tours ce
soir dans cette ville garante d'une
loire vivante et si c'était une question
d'éducation
éducation à l'environnement éducation la
nature éducation développement durable
éducation à la transition écologique
il ya beaucoup de façons de la nommer
cette éducation qui est née il ya une
soixantaine d'années
mais le propos est toujours le même il
s'agit d'apprendre une nouvelle façon
d'habiter la terre et pour ça on a tous
du chemin à faire
albert einstein disait la connaissance
vient de l'expérience
tout le reste n'est que de l'information
alors je vais vous inviter à vivre deux
expériences pour la première j'ai
apporté une plume l'éducation à
l'environnement
elle fait vivre des expériences de
nature et des expériences de société
c'est plus mal était encore accroché à
son oiseau il ya pas longtemps dans ciel
et elle est tombée et en tombant
évidemment comme tout ce qui tombe elle
a fait du bruit
écoutez
vous avez entendu peut-être tout le
monde n'a pas entendu que ce n'est pas
forcément une question de compétence il
ya eu quelques bruits parasites on
recommence attention deuxième essai
cette forme d'antan on écoute bien tous
ensemble voilà cette fois tout le monde
a entendu ou presque
on a fait cette expérience parce que l'
écoute est au coeur de l'éducation à
l'environnement l'écoutent de la nature
évidemment mais aussi l'écouté des
autres et une écoute de soi maintenant
attention deuxième expérience un peu
plus difficile je vous invite à faire la
connaissance de la personne qui à côté
de vous ou derrière ou devant que vous
ne connaissez pas vous avez 20 secondes
pour échanger votre prénom dire là d'où
venaient ou ce que vous voulez vingt
secondes top chrono
merci merci d'avoir joué le jeu merci
beaucoup d'avoir joué le 2 merci de
jouer si bien le jeu top
l'eba secondes son passé et vous assure
vous pouvez vous retrouver à la sortie
merci
pourquoi on a fait cette deuxième
expérience pour deux raisons la première
c'est que aussi au coeur de l'éducation
l'environnement se trouve le faire
ensemble et avant de faire ensemble il
faut échanger et avant d'échanger faut
se rencontrer
la deuxième raison c'est que l'éducation
à l'environnement aime bien mettre en
correspondance le geste et la parole
la question de la cohérence je fais ce
que je dis je dis ce que je fais en fait
pour moi cette aventure de l'éducation à
l'environnement
elle a commencé en 79 j'avais 24 ans je
cherchais ma voix est le mot qui
revenait c'était nature nature nature et
coup de chance de tomber sur ce métier
d'animateur nature et pour commencer
dans cette voie il était proposé de
passer le bafa le brevet d'aptitude aux
fonctions d'animateur et se bat face je
vais passer à quelques kilomètres d'ici
en forêt de chinon et tout de suite ça a
été une révélation
parce que nous étions dehors parce que
nous vivions la pédagogie de projet
parce que j'étais avec des passionnés de
nature et puis c'était le printemps
le plaisir était de tous les instants
dans les apprentissages la bienveillance
des arts pour les autres était une
évidence pour moi tout de suite ça fait
sens j'avais trouvé ma voie en fait je
l'ignoré complètement mais j'avais un
seul bagage élevé à la campagne j'avais
vécu beaucoup d'expériences de nature je
vais
couru les bois vous avez couru les prêts
j'avais construit des cabanes
j'étais monté dans les arbres des
centaines de fois j'ai passé des heures
et des heures dans des jarres et puis
j'étais à pêche mais souvent je jouais
du lance pierre et pas mal d'oiseaux on
en fait les frais et il ya eu l'épisode
de la chouette hulotte j'avais 12-13 ans
elle était en plein jour sur une branche
de pommiers j'étais à une vingtaine de
mètres j'ai hésité et puis j'ai tiré et
elle est tombée et j'ai couru vers le
pommier et j'ai prise en main et là j'ai
eu tout de suite le sentiment que j'ai
fait quelque chose que je ne devais pas
faire
j'avais détruit la beauté jeu couru vers
la maison l'a montré à ma mère et lui
dire n'en parle à personne
j'éprouvais une terrible monte oui
j'avais beaucoup d'expérience de nature
mais j'étais livré à moi-même j'étais
livré à l'ignorance et aux préjugés
coup de chance
mon frère y avait trois ans de plus que
moi m'a mis dans les mains le peterson
le peterson c'est le guide des
ornithologues et j'ai troqué le lance
pierres contre des jumelles et la
connaissance est venu remplacer mme
ignorance
très vite après ce stage j'ai fait des
dizaines de classes vertes de classe de
mer de classe de montagne j'ai fait les
chambres de vacances de découverte de la
nature
j'ai formé des animateurs mais cette
fois en tant que formateur ou ou
directeur et très vite je me suis rendu
compte que cette éducation à
l'environnement
elle marchait sur deux jambes elle
marche sur la jambe de la relation entre
la nature et elle marche sur la jambe de
la participation citoyenne
la relation entre la nature souvent dans
les classes vertes
un enseignant un système pour les
enfants partent avec un cahier un crayon
les enfants se retrouvaient dans les
chemins avec un cahier un crayon et puis
moi je fais la moue se toucher les
feuilles brader le caillou et très vite
des enfants en bas quelques à noter
peut-être deux ou trois choses mais les
cahiers été très vite oublié et le droit
étaient donnés aux mains de touchés 2
touchés ce qu'il ya autour de touchés 2
touchés et d'entendre et d'ouvrir les
yeux et aussi de sentir et aussi de
goûter et et aussi de goûter d'être au
contact de la nature au contact de la
nature c'est à dire faire la connexion
ou tout simplement la faire parce que
beaucoup de gens n'ont pas cette chance
de connaître la nature très tôt et ça ça
va nous emmener très vite à
l'émerveillement à la contemplation et
sa porte du calme et on se sent bien et
c'est d'autant plus important
aujourd'hui que des chercheurs
américains ont mis à jour cette idée de
syndrome de manque de nature oui quand
nous manquons de nature quand nous
manquons de nature quand nous manquons
de ce bain de nature on arrive à avoir
ce qui s'appelle le syndrome de manque
de nature et des maladies comme la
myopie l'obésité l'hyperactivité la
dépression peuvent être limités par une
fréquentation assidue de la nature
je prône l' approche sensorielle
puisqu'il compte en premier c'est d'être
avant de connaître ça veut pas dire que
je disqualifie l' approche scientifique
ou l'approché intellectuelle
pas du tout puisque quand on va voir
très vite on va observer
très vite on va décrire puis on va
nommer puis on va essayer de comprendre
les mécanismes relations entre les
plantes les animaux
on va être dans le court dans la leçon
d'écologie 7 le show cette leçon
d'écologie qui nous dit les cas de
grands principes que tout le monde
connaît ici j'imagine qu'on valait
rappeler un jeu vient de l'est tout
vient de l'énergie nous sommes des
poussières des toiles et la vie c'est
principalement une circulation
d'informations et d'énergie 2
la diversité c'est la richesse plus on a
d'espèces animales plus on a des espèces
végétales présentes sur un milieu et
puis ce milieu et productif est stable
voyez les forêts tropicales où les
estuaires 3
la nature ne fait pas de déchets les
rejets de l'ins et la ressource de
l'autre 4 et c'est peut-être le plus
important
nous dépendons tous les uns les autres
nous avons les êtres vivants ça d'avoir
un destin commun et c'est le principe
d'interdépendance si c'est bien de se
sentir bien dans la nature au point de
vue sensorielle et intellectuel c'est
bien aussi de se sentir en phase avec
spinoza quand il dit on ne saurait
rester inactif si on est menacé de
destruction
oui menacée de destruction l'année 2016
a été la plus chaude depuis qu'on fait
des relevés météo l'un des 17 sera
probablement plus chaude que l'année 16
les espèces disparaissent les pollutions
augmente
l'inquiétude croît il est urgent d'agir
la deuxième grande découverte que j'ai
fait dans ce stage c'était les
pédagogies actives
il s'agit là d' apprendre dans la vie
c'est au vide decroly qu'ils disaient
l'école doit être partout où est la
nature partout et la vie partout où elle
travaille on vit en faisant et on fait
dans la vie et on apprend dans la vie en
faisant or c'est simple on en est un
petit peu parlé on fait du terrain on va
dehors on se confronte à la réalité
on travaille en petits groupes c'est
comme ça qu'on apprend à faire ensemble
on fait appel à toutes les disciplines
c'est interdisciplinaire bien sûr on est
dans la pédagogie de projet on apprend
en faisant beaucoup de créativité
ensemble créativité collective
on apprend à s'exercer au débat on
apprend à travailler avec des personnes
de différents âges on apprend à venir
conseil à prendre des décisions
collectives à les respecter toutes les
façons d'apprentissage c'est pédagogique
qui viennent du xxème siècle pour la
plupart on connaît montessori on connaît
steiner on connaît freinet et il y en a
beaucoup d'autres
ils ont constitué un véritable trésor
pendant tout le xxème siècle et ce
trésor n'a pas été réellement utilisés
aujourd'hui l'espèce humaine a besoin
d'innovation
elle a besoin de personnes qui ont
confiance en elle l'espèce humaine a
besoin de personnes qui prennent des
initiatives
et là je pense à cet exemple vous
connaissez sans doute ce jeune
hollandais à 16 ans il se baigne dans la
méditerranée les fonds sont magnifiques
il est émerveillé et ils rencontrent pas
mal de plastique et ça ça lui plaît pas
beaucoup à 17 ans l'année d'après il
concevait un procédé pour retirer les
plastiques des océans quatre ans plus
tard
il avait réuni 2 millions de dollars
grâce à un crouch holding qui a mobilisé
trente mille personnes de 160 pays nous
sommes nombreux à rêver nos séances en
plastique
je parle de boyan parce que il est très
jeune quand il prend cette direction est
cette direction qu'il a prise importante
dans sa vie elle importante pour lui
certes mais elle est aussi importante
pour nous faute et y penser et je pense
à ses enfants de 9-10 ans 12 ans qui
aime la nature qui aime la terre qui
aiment la paix qui aiment les plantes
qui aime les bêtes ces enfants qui ont
des rêves dans l'esprit dans la tête
si on leur donne une pédagogie bien
adapté ils sauront ils seront par
eux-mêmes agir entreprendre avec les
autres dans un esprit de responsabilité
ils ont acquis de l'autonomie ils seront
socialiser efforts dans l'expression de
leur créativité
voilà ces pédagogies actives ce qu'elle
apporte
et c'est aujourd'hui très nécessaire les
territoires il est important de miser
sur la jeunesse et de donner à la
jeunesse la possibilité de vivre des
expériences très tôt des expériences
pensons pas connaissance pensons
expérience et là dans les territoires
vous connaissez tous certainement des
exemples vous connaissez des cantines
bio
ce sont des personnes qui ont pris la
décision à jour d'agir pour que dans la
cantine de leurs enfants ce soit des
produits biologiques et c'est comme ça
que ça commence on commence avec 10% 20%
peu importe ça continue après et on peut
arriver à 100% on a des composts
collectifs
on a des jardins partagés
on a des monnaies locales et tout ça ce
sont des moyens d'aller vers la
transition écologique
tout ça c'est bon pour la planète
aujourd'hui on a déjà prouvé certaines
choses nous l'espèce humaine
je la porte juste trois exemples et le
premier essai et ce faucon pèlerin vous
vous reconnaissez peut-être et qui avait
quasiment disparu des ciels du ciel de
france complètement disparu du ciel de
belgique dans les années 70 cette
année-là 2017
rien qu'à bruxelles il ya douze couples
qui s'empoignent se reproduire on peut
d'ailleurs les voir tous les jours
suffit de cliquer sur internet
c'est un show permanent en 90 il restait
14 espèces de poissons dans la seine
il n'a plus que 30 aujourd'hui
rappelez-vous les années 2000
l'angoissent pour la couche d'ozone
maintenant c'est quasiment d'ailleurs
noël en train de reconstituer
ça devrait être fait dans les années 50
on sait rectifier le tir aujourd'hui la
situation est très grave
probablement plus graves que toutes
celles que j'ai cités mais la capacité
de l'espèce humaine à prendre des
décisions et à s'organiser
elle est très content de 6 alors sept
changements qu'elle a devant nous le
changement de soi le changement des
organisations le changement des
territoires on peut jouer sur les trois
tableaux après tout pourquoi pas et
faire échanger en faisant et là on a un
grand grand allié et ce grand allié
c'est la beauté
rappelez vous de la chouette j'ai manqué
cinq ans c'est la beauté et la g3 bonnes
nouvelles la première c'est qu'enfin les
humains ont quelque chose à faire
ensemble et là il s'agit pas de
construire une grande nation dans
l'opposition à d'autres grandes nations
non il s'agit de retrouver les grands
équilibres écologiques
j'suis d'accord on en a pour quelques
années deuxième bonne nouvelle
ces petites rivières de l'éducation à
l'environnement que certains d'entre eux
vont peut-être n'ont pas encore vu
depuis 40 ans qu'elle coule elle est
rejointe en ce moment par une autre
rivière plus grosse tumultueuse c'est la
rivière du pr nouveau éducatif ce
renouveau éducatif il enfin vivre en ce
moment dans les établissements dans les
territoires par dans les pays même
koopmans finlande ont misé sur des
nouvelles valeurs comme la confiance la
confiance donnée aux enfants la
confiance donnée aux enseignants et ça
change tout et on avance notre notre
possibilité aujourd'hui pour ce
changement
probablement c'est l'ouverture et la
rencontre après ça fait son chemin à moi
ce soit la rencontre d'abord l'ouverture
après mais j'avais sur son chemin notre
parole partagés c'est le meilleur chemin
vers l'intelligence collective alors
multiplions les rencontres nous épie
longs échanges faisant naître des
projets
écoutons ceux qui sont dans le geste
ceux qui sont dans l'action on a déjà la
société civile qui a fait des réseaux
d'éducation à l'environnement qui a fait
des collectifs qu'à créer avec ses
partenaires de l'état des collectivités
des entreprises des espaces de
concertation pour une question de
l'environnement
il ya le grand mouvement des assises de
l'éducation à l'environnement qui est un
mouvement international et tout le monde
peut faire des assises dans son quartier
dans sa ville dans son département
il suffit d'approcher wagon le wagon le
train est parti depuis des années 2000
et la maintenance il est quatrième à 6
déjà elles sont internationales voilà on
a la possibilité de changer
on peut s'ouvrir à ceux qui font leur
donner la parole
ils ont quelque chose à nous dire et
nous tous c'est certain c'est clair
nous avons quelque chose à faire merci
[Applaudissements]